大家好，欢迎大家收听星期的生物节码。我是主播Kirsten，我是主播小诚，大家好，我是小水。
今天我们来讨论一个大家都很关心的问题，吃。
我们聊这话题的契机是我和小水最近不约熬童的，用了一个动态血糖监测仪，
然后我们就对这个血糖的控制以及碳水产生了浓厚的兴趣。
所以我们今天也很容易性请到了一位嘉宾，是我的一位非常好的朋友，也是代谢营养学的博士，
陆陆作为我们这次的嘉宾，跟我们一起来讨论这个话题。
对，而且因为我们当时知道陆陆不仅是营养学专家，而且他也不约熬童的带上了这个动态血糖仪。
对，但我们来介绍嘉宾之前，我想先和小水来分享一下我们为什么要用这个动态血糖监测仪。
你说当时我们看到这个动态血糖仪，是不是因为过了30岁之后，大数据精准地找到了我们，
然后同时都给我们进行了这么一个推送。
然后我当时看到了这个广告之后，我为什么要用这个呢？
主要是两个原因吧。
首先，第一个我是比较喜欢data driven的人，就是我特别喜欢看关于自己的数据。
我觉得数据可以帮我很好了解自己，然后你看睡眠有什么数据啊，那血糖有什么数据，我当然就很感兴趣。
然后第二个也是因为就是我的老了，其实他是有这个糖尿病当时，
他糖尿病，然后后来有儿子喊莫症，当然我们现在知道这两个之间有点关系。
但是的确是在这个血糖仪之后，让我对之前很多吃什么呀，要怎么吃啊，然后要好好睡觉这种，
之前就是怎么说我们都不听劝的一些经验，有了一个具体化的数据，
然后改变了我的整一个生活习惯。
对，我也有同感哦。
我用这个血糖监测仪有一个原因也是比较好奇，自己的血糖在吃不同东西之后到底会怎么变。
但还有一个原因也是因为我前几个月，我自己觉得我身体不是很好，
经常会处于一个脱水的状态，然后睡眠有点问题。
然后一问Chad GPT，他说第一个可能理由就是你可能患了糖尿病，
但是我吓死了，我就很不理解啊，我说我是一个兽子啊，我们的听众可能看不到我没有感觉，
但可能可以从我这个讲话中气不足推乱出，其实我是一个体重略微低于正常值的这么一个人。
所以说我就在想我怎么可能就得糖尿病呢？
但是我还是出于好奇，我就买了一个这种血糖监测仪，
然后后面这个数据确实让我非常震惊，也有了很多思考，
那我们今天就来好好讨论一下这一点。
那么首先我想再次隆重欢迎一下我们的嘉宾Lulu。
大家好，我是Lulu。我博士期间做的是代谢营养学相关的研究，
然后我本人对糖尿病非常感兴趣。
对，其实我第一次认识Lulu的时候就是我们一起面试博士项目的时候，
我当时本科的时候也是对营养学非常感兴趣，也俯修了一个营养学，
然后当时也做过一些关于肿瘤营养学的研究，
然后当时在面试某一个项目的时候就碰到Lulu，
然后刚好我们还是杭州的老乡，
就没想到最后我们俩都没有去那个项目，
而是在湾区相遇了，一个到了UZ伯克利，一个到UZSF，
然后那就自然而然成为了最好的朋友。
那我想让Lulu来给大家分享一下，
为什么当时你会选择去学习代谢营养学。
我其实学这个的原因跟小水对糖尿病感兴趣的原因很像，
因为我的妈妈还有我的外公他们都有二类糖尿病，
然后在我高中的时候我来到了美国，
在美国中部叫Wisconsin的一个地方，
然后当时我的技术家庭的爸爸也有糖尿病，
但是我母亲那边的糖尿病的病症呢，
跟我技术家庭爸爸的糖尿病的病症看起来不太一样，
就是一边是瘦瘦的一边是肥胖导致的二类糖尿病，
所以我当时对这个非常感兴趣，
然后大学我修了一门内分泌的课，
更多的了解到糖尿病，
所以后来我大学毕业之后，在选择博士项目的时候，
我决定去研究糖尿病。
对，我们一般人可能上那份密学，
就是被那几个名词都非常的痛苦，
但是陆陆当时肯定已经显现出作为一个科学家的天性了，
从这门课里面会对这个糖尿病也产生非常浓厚的兴趣。
那我们先从一个非常简单的问题来看，
就是什么是糖？
我们经常在生活中会说到糖，说到碳水，
然后经常会把这两个名词，碳水化合物，
和糖这两个名词做一个混淆。
那究竟什么是糖？
我们平时说的糖，它跟碳水化合物有什么区别呢？
糖在广义上是指碳水化合物，
但是按它化学结构的复杂程度可以分为单糖，
我们也叫monosecariot,。
双糖disecariot,。
那双糖是有两个单糖组成的，
它可以被水解。
还有就是多糖，叫polisacariot，
就是有许多单糖，
通常是葡萄糖聚合而成的大分子。
那单糖呢，
它是可以直接被小肠吸收进入血液的，
所以一般你吃到单糖，
它对于血液生糖的影响会比较大。
它也是我们细胞能量代谢直接原料。
我们通常说的单糖有三种，
一个是葡萄糖，果糖，
这是在水果中能找到的，
还有一个是叫半煮糖，
那双糖呢，就是有两个单糖组成的，
比如说遮糖、乳糖和麦芽糖，
那遮糖的话是由葡萄糖和果糖组成，
乳糖是由半乳糖和葡萄糖组成，
麦芽糖是由两个葡萄糖组成。
所以就这几个单糖，
然后排列组合，
排列组合，
组成各种双糖，
对，组成各种双糖。
所以说我们说的lactose free milk一般，
就是它已经把乳糖给它水解成葡萄糖和半乳糖了，
你喝的时候你会觉得lactose free milk是有点甜的。
对。
但是它从能量的角度来说，
一般是一样的。
哦，是这样。
就是如果说你想要喝点甜甜的牛奶，
你可以喝lactose free milk。
或者你乳糖不耐的话。
对。
那我们最后一个更复杂的糖，
叫多糖，
叫polysaccharide,。
它们通常来说不甜，
它需要经过煤的分解成为单糖之后才能被吸收，
通常它们是作为能量储存，
或者结构的成分。
那多糖的分类有三种，
一种是叫starch，
它是植物的能量储存形式，
还有一种是glycogen，
是动物的葡萄糖储存形式，
它通常是在我们的肝脏和肌肉中，
还有最后一种叫纤维素，
它是植物细胞币的组成，
也是由葡萄糖组成的，
但是不能被直接吸收。
所以葡萄糖主要是在什么样子的食物里头？
比如说我们平常吃的淀粉，
它被分解之后，它就是有葡萄糖。
然后葡萄是基本上就在水过滤的比较多？
对，拌乳糖就是在乳制品的比较多。
刚刚我们讲到了单糖、双糖，
也就是这些简单糖和复杂糖、多糖的一个区别，
那我们平时在我们中国人、东亚人习惯的饮食里面，
我们会接触到哪些食物里面是含糖的呢？
这就很多了，比如说我们南方人喜欢吃大米饭，
那基本上纯纯的就是淀粉，
那它的确对我们血糖的影响还比较大，
那北方人吃面可能比较多，对吧？
这也是淀粉。
然后我觉得中国饮食我特别觉得很醒目的一点，
就是我们的早餐跟美国人不同，
我们基本上都是大量的碳水炸弹，
比如说油条，
像我们杭州人我们早上一般会吃什么呢？
我们会吃小龙包，吃我们的小馄饨，
然后那小馄饨基本上就是一点点的肉，
然后大部分都是皮，然后再喝汤。
我以为我想到蛋白质可能就是一个水煮蛋，
但是这样的蛋白质含量就没有这么高，
大部分都是糖，
所以碳水在我们中国人的饮食中是占很大很大比例的。
就除了米饭之外，还有像土豆、红薯这种，
也大部分都是淀粉嘛，
然后小时候就特别喜欢吃土豆丝盖饭，
然后现在回想起来就是碳水加碳水。
我觉得我们有很多东西都是这样，
比如说那个巴斯第一瓜，
也是碳水加碳水，
土豆丝卷饼，
对,
我们可能会把土豆这种归类在蔬菜，
但其实它的那个主要的营养下去是碳水化合物。
那我们平时会想到糖的话，
可能经常想到了就是奶茶，
可乐,
这种非常甜的东西，
但其实就像我们刚刚说的，
吃了很多主食，
甚至我们认为是蔬菜的一些东西，
它的碳水含量都很高。
那我们平时会这样说，
我们要控糖，
那我们是要去控制，
总体的碳水含量呢，
还是说我们要去控制，
像是添加糖，
这些淡糖，
双糖这样的简单结构的糖。
嗯，说到点子上嘛，
其实我们应该控制的是添加糖，
所以我希望在美国高中有一门必修课，
就是教你如何去毒，
营养成分表，
这个我感觉是很多人不太会去干的事情，
一般买东西，
他们就可能看一些就organic这种标准，
所以说你如果说看每个食物，
后面它的那个成分表的话，
你可以看到它会有一个addish sugar，
如果这个食物它addish sugar比较多的话，
说明它添加糖比较多，
这样的事我们应该尽量去避免涉入。
对，我也是来美国之后，
也是上大学的时候，
上了一节像营养课，
它教我们怎么去阅读这个NutritionFacts，
也就是营养成分的表格。
而且我也注意到，
如果我们从亚超买东西，
或者直接从中国买零食，
它后面是不把添加糖给区分开来的，
其实是一个挺不好的事情。
这样你就没有办法知道，
有多少糖是来自碳水，来自纤维，
有多少糖是后面加上去的。
对，你刚提煎维那个点非常好，
因为纤维我们刚刚说到也是碳水化合物，
但它是不会被我们吸收的，
所以这个其实我觉得，
应该是在碳水化合物里面更细分开来，
如果说这个碳水化合物很高，
但你不知道，它主要是来自于添加糖，
还是来自于纤维的话，
其实这个营养表给你的提供的信息非常有限。
对，那很多人要控制碳水是为了减肥了这个目的，
为了减肥，
我晚上比如说不吃饭，
或者说我就干脆不吃米饭，
或者我们要控制这个碳水的涉入，
陆陆你在对这个低碳水饮食这方面你有什么看法？
首先，低碳水饮食对本身血糖有问题的人，
比如说有糖尿病的人来说，
它肯定是有很有帮助的，
因为你首先就是减少糖的涉入，
那你对遗导的刺激也会比较少，
但是如果你从减重的角度来说，
有很多研究发现在同等热量下，
如果说你涉入低碳和高碳的饮食，
在有样的热量缺口的情况下，
是没有什么长期的明显差异的？
就提到减肥，
经常会说一句话，
就卡路里就是卡路里，
你的卡路里是从碳水来的，
还是从脂肪来的，
其实并没有什么特别大的区别，
你要减肥，
最后还是要这个关注嘴，
脉开腿。
如果说是在同样卡路里的基础上，
你无论是怎么个配比，
然后对于你以减肥这个目的来讲，
都没有太大的区别是你的意思吧？
对，对，就是有很多研究就发现，
大概六个月到长期到一年左右，
低碳和高碳减重效果是没有明显差异的，
但是在低碳组他们有发现，
该由三指的level是有降低的，
然后同时HD，
也就是我们说好的弹固醇有变高，
然后空腹一到数降低，
所以说他们从代谢的这些指标来看，
低碳组是更健康的，
但是从减重的角度来说，
这两组没有任何差别。
那我们还有个很流行的，就是生酮饮食，
不知道这些研究里面有没有提到生酮饮食，
它的到底对减重，
或者整个代谢的指标是有没有好处的？
生酮饮食就是相当于这里面的低碳组饮食，
我觉得生酮饮食在短期之内的确会。
达到一个比较好的减重效果，
因为你没有糖的涉入的肝脏的话，
它会开始breakdown，
就是开始分解你的糖原，
那每一个糖原它本身自己有重量，
它同时每一颗糖原，
它要结合三到四颗水分，
所以说你在短期一两个礼拜之内，
似乎有一个减重的效果，
那主要是来源于肝脏糖原的消耗，
还有它水分的消耗，
我个人就是因为我带那个石石血糖。
一两个礼拜，我其实瘦了一公斤，
然后现在又回来了，
然后我就发现那一公斤，
其实并不是减肥得到的，
而是因为我减少了我的糖涉入之后，
我的肝糖原，还有我的水分，
确实那一公斤就很快掉下去了，
但是我现在正常吃饭之后，那一公斤又回来了。
就是相当于在长期的观察之下，
这个其实是没有太大的区别，
当然我们就是为减重，
不是为了减重，
其实也是为了有更好的身体，
对，如果我们就是。
以着健康为标准的话，
那其实低碳组，
在整体身体的这个状况来说，
还是会更有力的，
是的，我所知道，就是生统颖石在某一些，
比如就有颠险的一些儿童中，
是有一些治疗的效果的，
但是对于健康人，对于普通人来讲，
这个可能好处不一定会大于。
所付出的这个整个过程。
我们知道生统颖石，
如果你要做到生统颖石的话，
那你可能就得吃超级高蛋白的食物，
或者是高脂肪类的食物，
然后你如果这个脂肪来源，
你想要一个好的脂肪来源的话，
你就要是不是大量的像牛油果，
橄榄油这样子的食物，
对于我们的这个颖石结构，
一个非常大的改变，也是挺折腾的。
那除此之外呢，
因为我们说生统生统嘛，
它就是会在你学院里面产生大量的这个同体，
其实对腎臟的功能也是有很大的符合的，
对于我们健康人来说，
考虑到它的一些弊端，
未必是一个很好的选择，
这是我一点个人感觉的，
因为我自己呢，
我是没有办法吃高蛋白高脂的食物的，
我吃牛油果我都会觉得肚子不舒服，
我的这个饮食结构里面，
可以低碳水，
但是还是需要一些碳水的。
我要是光吃肉，光吃牛油果，
我就会觉得不舒服。
是的，之前我有尝试过一段时间生统，
就是吃了一周以后，
就感觉一旦脑子晕转的时候，
转不动了，就感觉脑部的糖，
它不够，就超级想吃糖。
对，我们知道大脑它的能量来源，
其实绝大部分都是来自于葡萄糖，
大脑是需要葡萄糖来供能的，
如果说我们强行的让大脑去适应用同体，
或者是其他的一些营养物，
其实是需要费一些精力的。
对，然后同体功能其实对养的要求更高，
所以你会感觉他们身体一直在发热，
然后他们的呼吸会更加的深。
这是为什么呢？
就是我们在代谢糖的时候，
是可以通过无氧的代谢，
就是糖教解，
然后再进入电子传递链，
这一部分是需要氧气的，
但是如果说是同体的话，
它是直接进入电子传递链，
那一部分就是需要氧气的。
而且一个同体比较葡萄糖，
比如说它同时完全氧化的话，
它们产生的ATP不太一样，
葡萄糖可以产生的更多一点，
大概到30到32，
那么一个同体它完全氧化，
它可以产出大概22到25个，
所以说从ATP的产能上来说，
同体没有葡萄糖可以产得那么高。
那我们说要减肥或者健康饮食，
除了低碳跟生酮以外，
还有一个很流行的饮食，
就是地中海饮食，
我们特别是在美国，
这边会倡导着地中海饮食，
那地中海饮食一大特点，
其实是它的红肉含量会比较少，
它们主要的蛋白质来源是海鲜鱼，
然后对于红肉，
比如说猪肉、牛肉，
这种脂肪含量比较高的肉，
它们就会避免去使用，
这是它们的一大特点，
另外一个特点，
就是它们相比起我们东亚饮食，
它们碳水射入量还是比较低的，
我们东亚饮食其实碳水，
射入量是相对比较高的，
在这个世界范围来说，
那地中海饮食另一大特点，
就是它们的那个碳水，
基本上就是全卖面包，
像是全卖面包一样，
就是未经加工的一些碳水，
可能可以说成一个粗粮，
但是我们经常射入的就是精米，
我们白米饭这些都是精米，
经过加工之后的碳水化合物，
那这些也会让它生糖指数变得更高一些，
意大利菜算是地中海饮食吗？
算,算,
对，但是意大利的碳水含量可不少啊，
但是你看意大利人，
它们的碳水其实是很多时候是结合，
蛋白质和油脂出现的，
比如说你去意大利餐厅，
它有一个餐前面包，
它不是只给你面包，
它会给你干了油，
会给它们的包桑莓格，
然后给你干了油，
这两个东西都是可以减弱你的生糖的，
就是粗的话酸性的环境，
它首先会让你的淀粉煤。
没有更好的去消化这个碳水，
因为它在酸性的环境中，
其实淀粉煤是没有办法工作的，
所以它首先那个淀粉，
它的那个分解的速度就变慢了，
然后在上油脂的包裹之后，
它极确会让你的血糖的影响会变少，
虽然它们碳水很多，
但是它的这个吃法是比较健康的。
对，我们刚刚就提到了，
我们今天的一个重头戏，
也就是生糖指数，
英文叫做Glasemic Index,。
生糖指数是指一个食物中的碳水化合物，
被我们人体消化吸收后，
它引起血糖上升的速度和程度的衡量，
这个的一个指标，
简单来说，
它就是反映一种食物，
它升高我们血糖的一个快慢，
那么我们经常会，
反正是我吧，
我经常会在网上看到，
这个所谓生糖指数，
跟这个健康的一个相关性，
那这个生糖指数到底重不重要？
我觉得生糖指数对于，
特别是对于糖尿病的人群来说，
是非常重要的一个指标，
那它是怎么衡量呢？
就假设他们把葡萄糖设为100，
就它的我们叫Area Under the Curve,。
曲线下面积设为100的话，
相同重量，
你要测试的食物，
它相对于葡萄糖，
它的那个百分比是多少，
那它还得到了这么一个，
我们叫Galaxymic Index,。
就生糖，
高级爱的食物，
比如说白米饭，白面包，土豆，
还有葡萄这种，就是高生糖的，
就是我们刚刚讲到了，
首先是金家宫的一些淀粉，
它的生糖指数就会比较快，
还有像葡萄这种，
带有果糖，
也就是简单糖结构的这种糖，
它的生糖指数应该会比较高，
所以多少算高啊？
七十以上，那中型的话，
一般中生糖的食物是。
五十六到六十九，
比如说红薯，
草米,
叶麦片，这种，
就是你可以看到，
它不光光只是淀粉，
红薯，比如说它有纤维在里面，
然后草米也是，
像这种淀粉和纤维结合的这种，
碳水呢，
它一般都属于中生糖食物，
我们刚刚提到那个名词，
叫做曲线下的面积，
就是因为我们每吃一个东西，
射入了碳水之后，
我们的血糖先是会升高，
就是立马就会有反应，
就是升高了很快，
但是呢，
我们体内会有一些荷尔蒙，
一老素，
它会帮我们调控这个血糖，
然后就会让这个血糖在，
基本上在饭后一两个小时之内，
就降低到正常的一个指，
当我们说这个曲线下面积的时候，
就是,
首先它升得多少高，
然后它下降的速度有多少快，
这两个指标，
也就是它的X周是时间，
它的Y周是血糖的，
血液中糖分的数值，
那它这样子去进行一个，
面积的计算，
那就相当于是说，
它高J值，
它不只是升得快，
它降得还得慢，
我觉得对于一个食物来说，
它可能是升的那个高，
最高点有多高，
最高的时候呢，
它肯定它的面积，
下面的面积会比较大，
不过你这个问的很好，
因为其实还有一个index，
叫做glaxemic load,。
叫做生糖附合，
它是把生糖指数
和它那个总共碳水的量，
都考虑进去，
那比如说有一些东西，
它是高级，
就是它生糖升得很快，
但它的glaxemic load 并没有很高，
它对你，
就是生糖的附合并没有很高，
它可能碳水总量并不是很高，
比如说西瓜，
因为它大部分都是水分，
它的确会让你有一个。
很快上去的一个数值，
但它整总量其实没有特别高，
也许很快就下来了，
但是白米饭和面包，
像这种十点点的碳水，
那它两个都非常高，
它不光你生糖升得很快，
同时它的那个碳水化量，
总量也比较高。
生糖指数和这个生糖附合，
也就是总的那个碳水量，
到底哪个更重要？
都很重要，对。
我觉得都很重要，
就看你的重点是什么，
我觉得一般来说，
如果你的血糖是你的手药，
健康问题的话，
你的生糖指数，
就是你那个p可以标多高，
其实它是直接对你倒数的，
刺激有多大是相关的，
就比如说，
你的确它这个碳水化量很高，
但是呢，
这个食物，
它并不会让你很快的就有个p，
它一倒数可以缓慢的释放，
去进行一个血糖调供，
那它可能对一倒的影响，
并没有这么大。
对，就是你吃一口西瓜，
可能吃五口就饱了，
因为它体积大，
含水量高，
但是你吃五口米饭，
你摄入的糖会多很多。
我自己有一个例子，
我有次在一个会议上，
叫这个火石一般，
然后我就吃了一个鸡肉三明治，
是鸡胸肉三明治，
首先鸡胸肉我们都知道，
是一个比较健康的东西，
蛋白质含量非常高，
我吃完那个三明治之后，
就发现我的血糖标准到了，
200毫克,
每 desiliter,。
就是已经超出我那个。
血糖监测仪的最高值了，
然后当时就很不解，
因为你不说鸡胸肉，
它很健康嘛，
然后里面又有芝士，
然后又有蔬菜，
相当于是有营养非常均衡的一个东西，
为什么我吃下去，
然后血糖就飙升了这个样子，
你不是一个蛤蜊，
因为我身边，
包括我自己，
我在吃三明治的时候，
也有一样的问题，
我当时想的也是这个东西，
好像三大营养素都在里面，
它又不是一个纯层的碳水的一个食物，
为什么会标这么高呢？
后来仔细想了，
它碳水是碳水，
蛋白质是蛋白质，
那个起司的脂肪是脂肪，
所以说，
他们三个同时进入到你的肠道里面的，
那碳水还是单独被消化，
被吸收，
并没有说是我们的起司和那个鸡肉，
把碳水包裹了，
会减缓碳水吸收，
那当然了，
你吃一口就是营养均衡的三明治，
肯定是比吃一大口白面，
肯定是生糖来的，
不会那么快。
这边又又过到了我们刚才，
对于这个伊拉利菜的讨论，
就是它的膨认方法，
我们刚刚说到伊拉利菜，
比如说我们吃面包的时候，
就是只吃面包，
而是蘸点橄榄油，蘸点醋吃，
这个其实是帮助我们，
避免快生糖这些效果。
是的,
因为我的确有一次我去外面吃披萨，
然后我在想，
披萨这么不健康，
又这么多碳水的东西，
我一会儿肯定看我那个血糖油，
应该会吓一跳，
但是我后来回去之后看了，
非常平稳，
它是一个缓慢的上升的状态，
然后就下来了，
也就是说，
当你的碳水和你的油脂，
紧密结合的时候，
它其实对你的血糖影响并没有很大，
但是你从卡路里的角度上来说，
它又不是那么的健康。
对，其实我有一个类似的发现，
就是我吃芝士蛋糕的时候，
我当时去，
三番这边一家非常有名的芝士蛋糕，
然后要了一杯抹茶，
要一杯芝士蛋糕，
然后我以为我也是会生糖很快，
结果发现血糖也非常的平稳，
然后我想说，
这是为什么？
那看来有可能它是芝士蛋糕的油脂比较多，
它就是混合得很好的。
对，当然可能虽然生糖慢，
但是它有这么多的脂肪，
然后有这么高的卡路里，
可能最后也不是一个好东西，
所以我们也不能单一地只看生糖这一个标准，
来评判一个食物，
但是芝士蛋糕还是很好吃的。
那再说回我个人的心得，
就是再回到这个鸡肉三明治的例子，
有没有什么吃法，
我可以避免我这个鸡肉三明治的，
后面只有血糖标准的情况呢？
把它拆开吃。
对，你可以拆开吃，
这就可以讲到一个，
有一项研究，
他们是把人分为两组，
都是糖尿病，二型糖尿病的病人，
然后他们同样吃一份西式套餐，
然后他们吃的顺序不一样，
一个是先碳水，
比如说面包果汁，
等个15分钟再吃蛋白质和蔬菜，
那第二组呢，
就先吃蛋白质和蔬菜，
再等个15分钟再吃碳水，
这个研究就发现，
先吃蛋白质和蔬菜的那一组呢，
在餐后不同的时段的时间点血糖，
比先吃碳水的那一组，
下降20%,
或者更多。
所以这个就说明，
不仅要吃得顺序好，
而且还得吃得慢。
对，中间还得等一等。
对，中间还得稍微等一等，
如果你吃完一口鸡肉，
然后立马就可以吃，
可能也没有这个效果。
所以说，
我们刚刚说到意大利人，
就是有一个研究发现，
地球上有些地方，
人的寿命可以很长，
那他们的饮食，
包括各家生活指标，
包括各家健康指标都非常的不错，
然后呢，
这个就被叫做Blue Zone，
那有意大利，
还有日本的一个，
好像是一个补鱼的村庄，
然后地中海地区的一些地方，
然后他们就发现，
不光他们饮食上有贡献，
比如说爱吃鱼，
吃这种Omega，
所以比较丰富的，
蛋白质比较丰富的食物之外，
他们还有一个很重要的贡献是，
他们很喜欢在一个Social Siting里面，
进食,
他们会家人一起共同吃饭，
那你想想，
你跟大家都要一边讲话，
一边吃饭的时候，
你是不是进食的速度就变慢了？
我就想起来，
我小时候我们家人吃饭，
我们也是喜欢晚饭在一起吃，
然后慢慢吃，聊聊天，
然后我当时我外公会，
习惯于先去吃菜，
可能配点小酒，
这个酒精的味道，
我们已经讲过了，先不讲了，
就是可能先吃点菜，
然后把菜吃够了之后，
再去添饭，
但是这个东西我们就很难做到，
因为我们以前在中学里，
特别就是中学里，
吃饭时间特别短，
给你十几分钟、二十分钟，
你得把什么都吃完，
那我就没有办法做到先去吃菜，
所以当时养成的习惯，
就是你有什么菜、饭，
就混在一起一起吃了，
那包括现在也是这样子的习惯，
但是听了陆陆刚刚说的，
我们现在可能还要细脚慢，
点先吃肉、吃菜，
最后再吃点米饭，
这样可能是一个对我们血糖。
更加有帮助的一个进食习惯。
那是不是说明我们。
之前小时候觉得自己是一个坏毛病，
现在可能是一个好的习惯，
就是我们有时候，
有时候我们吃饭的时候喜欢看电视，
然后你吃吃了，
你就看电视，
你就忘了吃饭，
然后你再回来接着吃，
这可能间接地帮助我们。
控制了我们这个选堂。
你的血糖控制住了，
我们爸妈因此非常生气，
或者双变高，
他们的压力和耳膜变高了，
他们的血糖出了问题。
我再分享一个个人的故事吧，
就是我佩戴动态血糖监测一着两周，
有一次就去吃了那个港式烧辣，
那不是很多肉吗，
插烧，然后烧鸭等等，
就那天吃了很多，
但是我的血糖就比较平稳，
也就是因为那天就先吃了肉，
然后最后可能再稍微配一点米饭，
配一点别的，
他的血糖没有升高这么多，
但是有一个困扰我的一点，
就是我刚刚也提过，
就我吃这种高脂的东西真的不消化，
我的血糖是平稳了，
我那天胃肠胃可难受了。
我其实也有类似的问题，
就是我在很饿的时候，
如果我就直接吃一个高蛋白的东西，
我胃会痛，
胃会脏气，
是吧,
所以说碳水冲破东西，
我们终于说很养胃，
的确是真的，
我感觉吃这时候饿的时候，
吃一个碳水，
吃一个粥，
这个血糖刺客，
我的确觉得很舒服，
好消化。
我这里有一个问题，
刚才我们介绍了生糖指数，
然后我们又说了，
如何避免我们血液里的糖迅速飙升，
那么实际上对大部分正常人来说，
即使血液里面的糖迅速飙升了，
我们移道都正常，
它迅速就下来了，
我们血糖还是平稳的，
然后很多人也就这么走完了一辈子，
也没什么错，
所以就是说我们为什么要。
避免血糖的几句飙升呢？
我们为了避免血糖的飙升，
是因为有一些人，
特别是异感的人群，
他们可能先天，
他们的移道功能就有障碍，
那如果你加速的去刺激它，
它可能移到更容易凋亡，
这样子长期以来，
它就不会产生移道速了。
所以说实际上，
如果我们比如说，
周围家里有小伙伴，
比如家族有这种
糖尿病的遗传史，
或者说，
有一些潜在的这种肥胖的症状，
所以在吃饭的时候，
可能会对这方面
需要更注意一些，
让我们的移道，
更长久的能够健康的。
为我们工作，对吧？
但我们既然提到了这一点，
我们就来详细的谈一下，
血糖是如何被各种。
荷尔蒙调控的，
以及糖尿病是什么？
就是我们可以调控。
血糖的荷尔蒙，
主要是我们刚讲的移道素，
那移道素，
它的主要功能是降低血糖，
那同时，
还有可以升高我们血糖的荷尔蒙，
比如说，
叫做谷克港，
也叫移高血糖素，
它在我们饥饿的时候，
或者在我们紧张的时候，
会分泌，
那它的功能是分解，
干糖原，
然后呢，
同时把这种糖分的量。
给它变高，
那这两个荷尔蒙呢，
都是在一线分泌的，
移道素呢，
是主要由背的细胞产生，
移高血糖素呢，
是由Alpha细胞产生，
我们会经常说，
糖尿病就是这个，
背它细胞出了问题，
就特别是一线的糖尿病，
就是背它细胞，
没有办法产生移道素，
那其实，
这我们移道里面，
不只有背它细胞，
也有Alpha细胞，
这个Alpha细胞，
就像刚刚讲的是，
来分泌这个移高血糖素，
对的,
二型糖尿病，
也是没有办法分泌移道素吧，
二型的话，
更多是移道素抗性，
比如说，
我们把移道素，
比做钥匙的话，
那它的受体，
移道素受体，
它是我们的锁，
也就是说，
我们有这把钥匙，
但是呢，
它锁有一点点深秀了，
所以这钥匙，
没有办法去开这个门，
让血糖进入细胞，
这个锁的哪里呢，
是在,
锁在细胞的表面，
就我们，
比如说，
我们肌肉啊，
各种细胞，
脂肪细胞，
就各类，
几乎是全身，
所有要用到葡萄糖的细胞，
他们都会有这个，
移道素受体，
那二型糖尿病，
如果它是，
锁出现了问题的话，
那注射这个钥匙，
注射这个移道素，
还管用，
就不太有用，
因为它是，
这把锁深秀了嘛，
那我们讲到，
这个一型，
跟二型糖尿病，
它们的发病原因，
是什么，
有什么区别？
我们一型糖尿病呢，
通常是，
因为自身免疫，
攻击,
破坏移道，
β细胞,
而导致的，
绝对移道素缺乏，
那它发病原因，
通常是，
有遗传因素，
还有环境有因，
那遗传因素，
比如,
遗传到特定的，
HLA等位级，
就是说，
有一些HLA分子，
会更容易错误的，
把相关，
抗原,
遞给自身，
反应性的，
剃细胞，
然后,
从而造成，
免疫反应。
那我们刚刚讲到的，
HLA呢,
就是,
我们的免疫细胞，
来识别，
本体,
和异体，
就如果说，
这个细胞是，
自己的，
我们就会沉低一段，
我们自己，
淡白了一个，
太短,
那让我们的，
免疫细胞知道，
说我们自己人，
你不要攻击，
但是如果说，
比如说，
这个细胞，
改变了，
或者说，
被感染了，
它就会沉低一段，
非自身的，
太短,
那这种情况，
我们免疫细胞，
就知道了，
我要消灭它，
那刚刚说的，
疫情疼药病呢，
就是我们的，
移道细胞，
它,
因为一些，
这不是我们自己的细胞，
就把它给攻击掉了，
所以它这个，
是一型疼药病，
一般都是后天获得的呢，
还是说，
它会有遗传因素在里头，
有一定的遗传因素，
就比如说，
刚刚,
遗传到，
特定的，
HLA等位级，
那它们，
更容易在，
比如说，
外界一些，
幼硬的情况下，
会产生，
一类疼药病，
会产生这样的免疫攻击，
那还有一些是，
那种环境因素，
比如说，
那某一些病毒，
B,
它和,
一型疼药病的，
关系最强，
也就是说，
如果说，
你有这样的，
遗传因素，
再加上，
你受到某种，
病毒外界因素的，
trigger的话,。
那它很有可能，
就会触发，
隐形疼药病。
嗯,
就是它不仅是，
有遗传因素在里头，
还有一个，
环境的优因，
在里头，
对对对，
对,那,
如果说，
有遗传因素在里头，
是不是发病年龄，
会更加早一些？
对的,
一般发病年龄，
会更加神奇。
嗯,
我们知道，
二型疼药病的，
一大幼因是肥胖，
我们待会儿，
也可以再详细，
讨论一下，
那,
一型疼药病，
它和我们肥胖，
体重,
或者饮食习惯，
有任何的关联吗？
一型疼病，
基本上和肥胖，
没有关联，
我大部分，
看到的一型疼药病，
它,
就是BMI,
都是正常的，
反而他们会很瘦，
因为他们，
没有遗传因素，
因为遗传因素的，
是防去储能的，
急速,
你没有遗传素的作用下，
你的能量，
不能进入到细胞内，
反而相对，
他们,
看起来会很瘦。
这就是为什么，
我这个，
做一个瘦子，
我去医院，
医生会问我，
有没有一型疼药病的，
家族病史，
一般是不会怀疑我，
是不是得了二型疼药病？
但是我觉得，
在美国这边，
大部分，
得二型的，
都是肥胖导致的，
但,
的确在我们国内的话，
有很多二型，
就像我刚刚说的，
就或者说，
是胖的人。
这里我想补充一下，
我一直关注的，
架图的一家，
公司叫做Sana Biotech,。
他就是专门做，
最一型疼药病，
进行一个治疗方案，
但目前只有一个，
临床病人的数据，
就是,
把遗导细胞，
在体外进行编辑，
首先呢，
把HLA的,
分子敲除，
这样呢，
减少被自身的，
免疫系统，
识别为义务的标记，
然后同时呢，
也要增强，
CD47的表达，
这样呢，
这个细胞，
你别吃我这个遗导细胞，
我是个好人，
然后呢，
再把这个遗导细胞，
再输入回，
病人的身体里面，
然后让这个，
输入的新的，
编辑的遗导细胞呢，
长时间的隐匿于，
人身体内，
始终在分泌，
这个遗导素，
然后它在，
人类的一个，
疫情,
临床试验中呢，
当然了，
只有一例目前，
在大概十二周，
到六个月的时间里，
有很好的控制，
这个对于，
疫情糖尿病病人，
是一个，
很好的未来这个疗法，
因为,
现在的话，
对于普通的，
疫情糖尿病病人，
他们只能，
长期打遗导素，
或者说，
他们可能需要，
进行一个，
长期的免疫治，
嗯,
感觉这个疗法，
应该会很贵，
对，很贵，
然后我觉得，
必须得，
在,
病发之前，
你可能就要，
先删查到，
你可能有遗传到，
这个,
遗感基因，
对吧，这个HLA，
对啊,
这些免疫之际，
还是有这些风险，
而且这些细胞，
也有,
癌变的可能，
因为他没有，
其他的一些，
调控手段，
去控制他了，
这边,
clarify一下,。
就是SANA,
他们做的是，
自体的意志，
还是,
异体的意志，
也就是说，
他们是把，
病人自己的，
遗导,
组织自身，
还是说，
用一个，
通用型的，
也就是，
我们off the shelf,。
他们目前，
用的是，
异体意志，
反应就，
有可能会出现，
这样子的反应。
但是我好像，
对以前有听说，
干细胞了法，
就是当，
医型,
完全发作，
他已经没有异导，
细胞之后，
有没有办法，
用干细胞，
让他,
自己再产生，
细胞,
对,
这个UCSF,
其实有，
挺多实验室，
在做这方面，
是的,
我们刚刚，
其实也，
已经提到了，
澳琴糖尿病，
他的一个，
很大的发病，
对,
因为,
我们在美国大部分，
看到的二型，
是由肥胖，
导致的，
我们升级的，
代谢组织，
比如说，
肝脏,
脂肪,
细胞,
对医倒数，
产生抵抗，
那肥胖呢，
尤其是，
内脏脂肪，
因为我们的脂肪，
有分,
是在皮下脂肪，
还是在内脏脂肪，
在内脏脂肪，
过多的话，
会吸引很多，
就是细胞聚集，
那他们同时，
也会释放，
会导致一些，
慢症的，
低度的炎症，
我们叫，
low-grade inflammation,。
同时呢，
它会释放，
大量的，
油粒脂肪酸，
就是,
我们的脂肪，
更容易去分解，
纯粹的脂肪，
会释放，
大量的油粒脂肪酸，
那这些，
炎症因子，
和这些油粒脂肪酸呢，
会一直，
移倒数，
通路中，
的一些信号，
那所以说，
这个也是有，
遗传因素在里头吗？
因为,
刚刚说是，
之前我还在南方，
Deep South 呆过,。
然后他们里，
就会有那种，
特别肥胖的人，
就到,
夸张到什么程度呢？
就是,
我们去坐那个过山车，
不是一般要，
放那个安全杠吗？
然后呢，
就会有人，
胖到那个安全杠，
就是没有办法卡住，
然后就很无奈，
得请他们下来，
但是,
就这样，
他们,
貌似也很健康，
就也不会有，
这个糖尿病，
就相当于是说，
虽然是因为，
肥胖导致，
但是有些人，
可以很胖，
所以我就好奇，
里面是不是有一些，
什么遗传因素在里头，
或者是，
有什么别的因素，
会导致这个，
二型糖尿病？
这就是我们，
回到刚刚说的，
就是脂肪，
存储的地方，
其实这也有，
很有关系，
就比如说，
我们有，
皮下脂肪，
那皮下脂肪，
相对来说，
是一个，
比较健康，
去存储，
脂肪的一个，
缓冲齿，
但是我们的那张脂肪，
就就是说，
会让我们，
有一个，
会释放，
严振因子的，
一个脂肪组织，
所以,
皮下脂肪，
相对来说，
是比较安全的，
一个脂肪，
然后呢，
你刚刚说到，
为什么就是，
一些美国人，
你看到的很胖，
但是呢，
好像也没有，
太大的问题，
因为他们的，
皮下脂肪很多，
他们皮下脂肪，
可以有，
扩张的很大，
但他们也许，
那张脂肪，
相对来说，
皮下脂肪的比例，
来说,
并没有那么大，
但是有很多，
亚洲人，
比如说我爸爸，
对,
啤酒度，
然后这个很有趣，
因为我当时选择，
我做博士的实验室，
因为,
我们实验室有一项研究，
他们就是看，
湾区的亚裔人群，
和,
非亚裔人群，
比如说白人，
不同的种族，
他们的皮下脂肪，
有什么不一样，
然后呢，
我们就发现，
在亚裔的人群中，
他们的皮下脂肪，
它的纤维化，
是更高的，
你可以把它理解成，
你的皮下脂肪，
被上了一个枷锁，
被放在一个笼子里面，
它到一定程度之后，
它不能再更大的去扩张了，
所以多余的能量，
它只能走你的，
内脏脂肪，
这条路，
所以你内脏脂肪很高，
虽然说你，
身体看起来是瘦瘦的，
但如果你去做一个，
Scan的话,
你可能发现，
你内脏脂肪很高，
也就是说，
因为这个原因，
我们亚洲人群，
可能更容易得糖尿病，
对,
我觉得你这个说的，
的确是，
先让我回想起来，
像国内的很多，
虽然看起来很熟，
但是,
的确是会，
比较集中在肚子那边，
美国这边，
有些人就是，
胖得很均匀，
对,
还很灵活，
所以你看到，
很多是理型神采，
那在中国，
特别是我，
以前有很多印度同事，
我感觉，
他们有糖尿病，
但是他们，
真的,
四肢是想瘦的，
所以像我们，
这种肚子不容易长肉，
但是,
四肢比较容易长肉的，
其实,
对这个，
糖尿病，
保护作用，
对,对,
比如说，
你的屁股，
你的腿，
容易长肉，
这种理型神采，
反而是，
从代谢的角度来说，
是更健康的。
所以说，
它的这个二型糖尿病，
可能跟肥胖有关系，
跟这个脂肪的分布有关系，
那像是，
基因方面，
有没有什么，
容易导致，
你更容易，
换二型糖尿病呢？
这个我们，
就可以说到一个，
非常有趣的假说，
叫做,
节减基因假说，
英文叫做，
也是为什么，
我对糖尿病，
感兴趣的，
一个原因之一吧，
这个假说，
是在1962年的时候，
由James V. Neal,。
提出的，
他的意思是说呢，
我们人类的，
基因组里面，
带有一些，
节减基因，
Sifty genes,。
这些基因在，
以前我们，
需要,
狩猎采集的时代，
能更好的，
更有效的，
储存能量，
当然是，
以脂肪的形式，
从而在，
饥荒的环境中，
生存下来，
也就是说，
基因在我们，
进食的时候，
能快速，
合成脂肪，
储存能量，
然后能在饥饿的时候，
更节约的，
去消耗我们的能量，
但是呢，
这些基因，
放在现代社会，
就有个问题，
因为我们，
现代社会的，
食物过剩了，
能力动量也减少了，
我们不需要去打裂了，
所以这些，
曾经帮助我们，
存活下来的，
基因反倒，
对我们的，
带泄造成了，
一定的负担，
嗯,
对,
但是有好奇是，
这个也不能解释说，
糖尿病的反应，
这么不一样，
就是现在研究，
有没有知道说，
这个,
二型糖尿病，
跟基因，
有没有什么关系？
后，有一些GWAS，
发现,
某一些，
调控我们，
星辰代谢的，
基因的snap，
的确会增加，
一些族群，
糖尿病，
患病的频率。
对,
但是我也是听说，
这些基因，
它本身的这个效应，
会比较小，
主要还是，
跟这个后天的，
饮食,
肥胖冷环境因素，
就叠加之后，
然后会有一个，
比较显著的，
上升这个，
糖尿病的风险。
对,
我们可以理解，
基因,
它提供了一个图扰，
但是,
后来会不会患病，
还是跟我们的生活，
喜欢有很大的关系？
对,
还是你，
种什么种子，
开什么花？
对,
那除了，
我们常见的，
一型二型糖尿病，
还有一个，
也是困扰，
众多,
尤其,
众多女性的，
一个糖尿病，
就是,
认身糖尿病，
一场,
会让,
这个怀孕的母亲，
更容易患，
糖尿病。
对,
从,
怀孕的角度来讲，
嗯,
母亲,
它有一定的，
移道出，
抗性,
其实是一个，
非常正常的存在，
因为,
在这个情况下，
你要给胎儿共能，
所以说，
你希望，
血液里的糖分，
是比较高的，
你能更好的，
在胎儿需要的时候，
能够,
获取,
这个葡萄糖，
所以说呢，
它会有，
能够变低呢，
能更好的，
给胎儿去提供能量，
对,
所以,
这个,
认身糖，
要并在，
很多女性，
怀孕期间，
是会发生的，
所以说，
在,
认身期间，
在怀孕的时候，
相当于是，
这个,
锁的,
这个抗性，
它把锁，
变得,
没有那么好使了，
嗯,
然后,
就会有更多的糖，
在身体里头，
然后,
这样子，
就能被胎儿，
生长的时候，
那发生的原因，
也是因为，
一种基础，
叫做,
胎盘基础的增加，
也叫,
Human Placenta Lactogen,。
它会,
一直肌肉，
就是我们的骨骼肌，
对葡萄糖的利用，
所以,
我们能优先的，
给胎儿提供能量，
对,
就是为了胎儿，
牺牲自己，
对,
为了胎儿牺牲，
但是,
为什么，
我们还要特别关心，
这个,
认身糖，
要并的，
这个,
中,
高血糖，
是,
会让胎儿，
长期的暴露，
在一个高糖环境中，
那,
血糖,
其实是，
会跨越太盘的，
所以,
胎儿的一线的，
B细胞,
会被迫的，
分泌更多的，
胎儿,
会产生一种，
它同时，
也是一个生长结束，
它会促进，
脂肪的成见，
胎儿,
会长得更大，
就是,
会造成一个，
巨大儿的现象，
也叫,
microsomia,。
那,
出生之后呢，
呃,
首先,
它出生，
就是一个问题，
因为,
过大儿的话，
你很难顺才，
你可能，
需要,
颇富,
那,
出生之后呢，
几代,
剪断之后，
母亲的血糖，
就,
一个,
低血糖的状况，
这会导致，
新生儿，
呃,
的死亡率变高，
哦,
对,
因为其实，
来运到中期的时候，
记得就是，
那,
喝一个小糖水，
然后呢，
你得,
空腹,
然后,
在一个小时之后，
它会测你的，
那个血糖，
然后,
据我所了解，
就是,
在这边的，
中国人，
在做这个测试的时候，
基本上，
很少听说，
第一次测试，
但是这样子，
对，然后，
如果没有过的话呢，
你就要开始，
实施监测你的血糖，
嗯,
然后,
预防这个，
认身糖尿病，
对,
所以说，
如果要避免，
这个,
认身期，
糖尿病的话，
就得,
再回去复习一下，
我们刚刚说的那些，
饮食指导，
如何避免，
血糖的飙升，
可以先吃肉，
先吃蛋白质，
然后最后再，
再过一段时间，
再吃碳水，
但是这个可能，
遗传也有一定的因素，
对,
因为我们的人种，
包括我们的生活习惯有关，
因为我觉得，
大部分亚洲女性，
她不是那么的高壮，
然后呢，
我们的骨骼肌，
可能,
也不是那么的多，
因为我觉得，
在美国，
华云期间，
大家是非常鼓励女性，
做多做一些运动的，
去维持你的肌肉量，
那肌肉是一个，
非常大的，
葡萄糖的一个使用者，
但是,
比如说，
我们在中国那边，
你在华云期间，
大家讲你不要动，
不要做激烈的运动，
不要干这干那，
保胎的方式是这样子，
那可能会让你的，
肌肉含量没有很多，
那也可能，
就像你刚刚提到，
为什么，
你看到很多亚洲女性，
在在做，
那个,
血糖测试的时候，
似乎,
第一次都不会pass，
对,
我一直觉得，
这可能是，
因为他们的一个标准的问题，
它这个标准比较适合于，
就是外国的女性，
可能不太适合，
我们亚洲女性，
对,
当然,
就觉得运动这个，
是一个很好的点，
但是,
其实,
怀孕的时候，
希望你可以，
在一定范围，
在安全的范围之内，
就是,
维持原有的，
或者,
降低原有的运动量，
而不是说，
你因为怀孕了，
然后,
突然增加运动量，
其实,
这个也是不可取的，
对,
我们这里，
就不得不干，
太一句，
女人真的不容易啊，
还有可能碰上，
认真期，
糖尿病这种问题，
那据我了解，
除了怀孕期间，
就其实，
我们的，
月经周期，
因为我们的，
激素浮动，
它也是会影响，
长的调，
是的,
我们月经呢，
通常,
分为,
三个主要期间，
暖炮期，
黄体期，
和月经期，
那暖炮期间呢，
是我们，
月经后，
排卵期，
那这时候的，
磁激素，
也就是，
我们的E2，
是变高的，
运激素，
相对来说，
较低,
那在这个时候，
其实,
磁激素，
可以增强骨格，
继对遗导素的敏感性，
也就是说，
这个时候，
我们身体，
在,
这个暖炮期的时候，
有一些健身教练会，
鼓励你，
做一些高强度的训练，
那同时呢，
它因为你的遗导素，
敏感性比较高，
它会一直，
肝脏,
躺一身，
也就是说，
你的血糖，
更不容易上升，
相对来说，
更稳定，
所以暖炮期间，
你血糖，
可能是，
最稳定的一个时候，
那黄体期呢，
是排卵，
后月经期，
那在这个时候呢，
运激素，
我们的P4，
升高了，
同时呢，
在这个时候，
由于,
运激素升高，
这个遗导素，
敏感性下降，
那会,
产生轻度的，
遗导素抵抗，
也就是，
你,
为什么会觉得，
在,
来月经之前，
你的食欲会上涨，
因为你可能，
身体没有更好的，
得到能量，
所以你总是觉得，
好像吃不够，
因为有一点，
遗导素抗性，
对,
我就很明显的，
这个感觉，
我之前，
就是预测，
我什么时候，
精气要来，
就是看我那天的食欲，
掐指一算，
然后日子快到，
然后这两天，
就是怎么吃都吃不把，
或者饿得特别快，
我就知道，
马上我的精气就要来了，
对,
我自从，
了解这个时候，
我就接受了，
我月经之前，
我就是想要狂吃的，
这个鞋子，
而且他们想吃甜食，
跟自己和解了，
对,
会想吃甜食，
因为有可能，
你有一定的遗导素，
抗性你的，
血糖,
你的身体，
并没有吃到那个血糖，
它大部分存在，
在你的血液之中，
对,
而且你的，
糖就是我们说的，
也是你合成，
很多激素的一个，
前提，对吧，
然后,
所以可能，
它也是在，
为这个，
精气要做准备，
对,
你接下来要，
大出血了，
所以,
它要先给你，
也储存一些能量，
就是,
女人不要，
难为自己，
想吃就吃吧，
都为了，
大出血之前，
储存能量，
那我们现在，
还很常见的呢，
就是有一些女性，
包括我自己，
会长期用，
病运药，
那如果长期，
用口服，
是会对我们的，
激素水平，
有一些影响的，
那这个，
会怎么影响我们，
血糖的调控？
嗯,
长期,
病运药的话，
有两种，
就是我们在说，
口服,
病运药，
一种是，
腹方口服，
病运药，
它英文名叫，
combine oral contraceptive,。
那它是，
同时有，
磁激素，
E2,
和运激素，
P4的,
叫progestin,。
还有一种呢，
就是,
运激素，
单方口服，
minipal,。
叫做微玩，
我们中文叫，
那它就是，
只有progestin,。
那它们这两个东西，
对血糖的影响呢，
其实是不太一样的，
就腹方口服，
我必须要，
它有磁激素的加成下，
其实,
会对我们，
遗倒素的敏感性，
有一定的减弱，
然后同时呢，
会增高，
甘油,
三脂,
在血液中的含量，
那,
虽然说，
甘油三脂是不好的，
同时,
高密度，
子弹白HD，
也就是，
可拉斯手也会，
有所上升，
但是呢，
如果我们看，
运击素，
单方口服，
病运药，
也就是，
微玩的话，
minipal的话,。
它其实，
对血糖，
对新陳代谢的影响，
没有这么大，
所以说，
如果你一定要选择的话，
从代谢的角度来说，
运击素，
单方口服，
病运药，
会更好，
但是运击素，
因为它只有一个几书，
它对你的服用的时期，
它准不准是，
有很大的要求，
就是你不能说，
今天早上吃，
明天晚上，
再吃一片，
也就是说，
你的那个服用期间，
它的窗口，
是非常小的，
你要非常准时的，
去服用，
才会达到，
一个很好的，
病运效果，
但是你复方的，
口服病运药，
因为它有两个，
几书的加成，
它的那个window，
是很长的，
比如说，
你今天早上吃，
明天中午吃，
其实差别，
不会特别，
对,
我觉得这边，
比较多的，
还是这个，
复方口服，
病运药，
对,
大部分都是复方，
然后呢，
我中间去做过，
一次学检，
然后发现，
我的HDL,
有变高，
然后呢，
我的LDL,
也有,
轻微的上升，
就是有到零界点，
那后来，
我查了文献之后，
发现的确，
某一些，
版本的，
磁机数，
它是,
会有这个效果的，
所以我就想，
如果说，
我之后也，
换成一个，
新的版本的，
磁机数，
因为现在有，
二代的，
磁机数，
那他们对，
血糖的影响，
会有,
第一点，
我可不可以，
这样理解，
就是它这个磁机数，
其实是，
人工合成的分子，
它跟我们，
体内的磁机数，
还是不一样的，
所以它，
可以通过，
合成的那个分子，
结构,
会为了调整，
而避免对，
血糖的影响，
或者,
减少对，
血糖的影响，
我但是，
没有意识到，
说,
硬要会对，
血糖造成，
一定的影响，
血糖监测译之后，
发现对血糖影响，
最大的，
你们知道是什么吗？
就是我血糖，
一直都是很稳定，
但是只要我，
前一天熬夜，
或者是没睡好，
我第二天的血糖，
就是,
控制不住的标声，
然后我只要睡的，
特别久，
第二天的血糖，
就是会很稳定，
就是我发现，
这个睡眠，
对我的血糖，
影响是最大的，
就是,
比所有的，
其他的方面，
都要大，
所以,
从此之后，
我再也不敢，
晚睡熬夜了，
这就是，
很大的由于，
就是你改变了，
生活习惯，
就是我，
就是老祖宗，
劝了我这么久，
我爸妈劝了我，
这么久都没有用，
结果,
看到自己的数据，
下一条之后，
立马自己就改了，
嗯,
的确是有很多，
这方面的研究，
有证明，
就是,
如果说，
你的睡眠障碍，
或者睡不足，
或者睡眠被剥夺的话，
嗯,
你的确，
在血糖调供方面，
会有很大的影响，
有一个，
非常里程碑，
性质的一个实验，
就是在1999年，
Speagle等人呢，
他们就，
睡眠剥夺了，
11名健康的男性，
他们平均年龄，
都在22岁左右，
有一组人呢，
他每一礼拜，
就整整的一个礼拜，
大概6天，
他只睡4小时，
另一组人呢，
每天可以睡到8个小时，
那他的饮食量，
活动量，
是完全被控制的，
结果显示，
当睡眠被剥夺的那一组，
他的葡萄糖，
在血液中，
清除率，
就是我们，
吃饭之后，
血糖会飙升，
下来的这个速度呢，
是降低40%，
那是一个，
非常非常大的的话，
那同时，
他的insulin response,。
也降低了30%，
那他这个，
检测的方法，
就是近时候，
在两分钟，
或十分钟看，
血液中，
遗倒数的量，
也就是说，
你的beta cell,。
对于,
生糖,
这件事情，
产生,
遗倒数的能力，
有了变化，
这个,
如果你睡眠不夺的话，
这个能力会减弱，
那这个是什么机制呢？
是因为你的，
已经因为，
睡眠剥夺，
过于兴奋，
那,
你的脾致唇变高了，
这会,
抑制你遗倒数的作用，
也就是说，
你的压力技术变高了，
那同时，
这会影响到，
你的遗倒数，
就现在，
你要说两点，
一个是你这个，
产生的这个，
钥匙少了，
嗯,
然后同时门，
好像就不太好使了，
对，门也不太好使，
钥匙,
太可怕了，
而且是在一个，
很短期，
仅仅六天的，
能看到健康，
青年,
会有这样的一个反应，
所以,
我们一定要好好睡觉，
太可怕了，
就是我想到了我自己，
我在过去几个月，
就没有睡好过，
可能就解释了，
为什么我的血糖，
是这么的，
啊,
不稳定，
对对对，
我的血糖，
为什么，
我们就说，
你要去测一下，
你的脾致唇吗，
那所以，
就是,
当你有压力的时候，
会达到同样的效果吗，
就是,
因为我们家，
脾致唇，
就是一个压力，
荷尔蒙嘛，
分为短期压力，
和长期压力，
长期压力，
比如说一直失眠，
你的脾致唇，
和心脏激素，
会变高，
这会导致，
糖一升，
就是在某种程度上，
你身体，
认为你是要，
进行一个战斗状态了，
所以说，
它会把血糖，
尽量留在你的血液中，
你的糖分，
留在血液中，
以共你肌肉去使用，
所以说，
当你压力激素高的时候，
你随时都准备战斗的时候，
你,
通常都会有一点，
对,Kirsten,。
随时都在，
准备战斗，
随时,
要不是准备战斗，
要不是战斗的状态，
对,
这里有一个很有趣的研究，
是在2020年，
发布的，
他们在，
以色列南部地区的人口，
维养本，
进行了，
40多万人，
的一次，
血糖检测的研究，
那,
他为什么选以色列地区呢，
因为,
他,
在以色列地区，
因为有很多战乱嘛，
所以说，
军事行动，
压力,
那么他们又把，
这些地区的人口，
分为,
高压人群，
或者高压地区，
和低压地区，
那他们发现在，
高压地区的人，
他的确，
他的,
脾致存，
量是上升更多的，
同时,
伴有,
血糖问题，
就是,
我们,
长期的压力下，
他对,
血糖的一个影响，
这,
通常是，
因为脾致存的原因，
那,
短期压力呢，
就是,
我们说的，
比如说，
我们受到，
惊吓,
疼痛,
运动,
或者急性感染的时候，
我们腎上腺素，
会分比，
也还有，
去甲腺素，
neural epinephrine.。
那,
在这个，
短期的压力下呢，
他会导致，
我们的肌肉和肝脏，
进行,
糖原分解，
以达到，
快速释放葡萄糖，
那,
他,
所谓的那个，
Response,。
也是一样，
都是时刻准备战斗，
对,
我有一次，
那个小时呢，
我去面试一个人，
然后我就，
越聊越开心，
越聊越激动，
我的身体，
把它解读成，
一个短期压力，
虽然说，
我是开心的，
去接受这个压力，
然后,
我回去看，
我的血糖，
我的面试之后，
其实,
飙升的，
比吃那顿饭还高，
而且,
在这个情况下，
下降的速度，
非常之缓，
因为我的情绪，
一直处在，
一个抗氛的状态，
就没有办法，
立刻come down,。
那你对吃饭来说的话呢，
这个,
我情绪上的影响，
对于血糖，
反应更大，
而且,
并没有很快的能力，
我有个陆似的经验，
我也有类似的经历，
对,
我的例子，
就是,
我要是跟人吵架的话，
我的血糖，
就会飙到很高，
也是跟露露，
刚刚那个例子一样，
就可能比我吃饭，
比我还要高，
对,
你,
你一定得去，
测一下你的，
扣着手，
你的鼻子纯，
我有一个类似的经验，
但是,
跟你这个有区别，
我也是，
开始工作了，
然后我就在那儿坐了，
大概坐了一个小时，
然后我发现，
哪怕我的血糖已经下去，
在我坐下的，
那一个小时之内，
它就开始，
不停地上升，
然后直到，
我觉得口渴，
去拿水喝，
然后我就，
去拿水，
走来走去，
他说,
就下来了，
然后我当然心想说，
哦,
原来,
饭后摆不走，
是有道理的，
对,
恭喜你动用我的肌肉，
但是你认为，
是因为你久坐这个行为，
还是因为你在工作？
我就一直在电脑前，
做一个动作，
因为,
后来,
我觉得可能是，
因为我们最大消耗，
糖源的地方，
像刚入伟说，
是我们的肌肉，
然后我在一个，
没有动的状态，
那可能我的身体，
还在吸收这个糖，
然后呢，
他就在释放这个糖，
但是又没有东西，
来消耗它，
所以他，
一开始我穿饭，
就大量进入，
然后我的一道素，
被分泌了，
然后他就把，
下降下来了，
然后但是这个，
过程并没有停止，
然后,
但是我没有，
没有肌肉，
上升了，
当我开始走动的时候，
然后我的腿，
要开始，
不停地消耗它，
之后,
它就很快地下来了，
也可能是你，
当时的工作，
让你有一个压力，
有一个关系的压力，
那也可能，
那不是后嘛，
也不是那么，
也不是那么轻松的，
所以我们刚刚，
已经讲到，
好多种不同的，
激素,
跟这个血糖，
都有关系了，
感觉这个血糖，
真的是很容易，
被影响的一个东西，
真的,
就短期，
有一个情绪，
就能影响的，
对呀,
就给我们分享了，
这么多有可能，
导致,
血糖含量变化了，
我们也分享了，
一些,
小tip,
就我们怎么样，
可以避免，
参考血糖的，
飙升,
然后也介绍了，
糖尿病的，
治病原因，
以及,
认证期，
糖尿病，
我们如果要避免，
这个认证期，
糖尿病的话，
应该注意一些什么，
那,
我们也分享了，
刚刚说到了，
这么多，
不同的激素，
它有可能，
对血糖含量的影响，
那我们今天的节目，
到这里了，
然后我们之后呢，
大家如果感兴趣的话，
我们也可以，
再继续展开，
血糖,
及糖尿病，
和其他疾病，
包括我们，
在做的神经，
退形型疾病系列，
这些有什么相关性，
我们之后，
也可以，
再专门开一期，
聊一聊，
那我们，
再次感谢，
我们的嘉宾，
陆陆来做课，
我们的播客，
谢谢陆陆，
谢谢,